2024 might be a very very interesting
year for Star Trek fans why welcome to
site Trek your Sci-Fi TV movie channel
I've been talking about Star Trek most
of this year and I've had to share
information that not everybody is liked
there are two camps within the Star Trek
fandom those that love all of Star Trek
in all of its forms regardless of how
good or awful it is even if it's a
musical they love it and there's the
people that hate newre
they detest it and they blame Alex
curtzman for all of it and want burn
Effigies of him in their Garden etc
etc I have always sort of tried to sit
in the middle I try to be
open-minded but I'm not as big a fan of
new Trek as I love all Trek I will still
watch Voyager D space9 TNG I just can't
get my headr Discovery I've tried I
don't like it and um but strange new
worlds lower decks blah blah blah love
it I've talked a lot about what's going
on at Star Trek at the moment and some
of the actual division even at Paramount
and Executives that are arguing about
what they want to do with Star Trek now
that has annoyed both sides of this
debate and I've been called a liar
several times um by different fans
because what I'm telling you the truth
of what's actually going on doesn't fit
with their own viewpoint on the subject
and the show so what have I told you
I've told you that there are Executives
over at Paramount that don't really know
what to do with Star Trek in the future
and actually don't like the direction a
lot of Star Trek has gone and I've also
told you that there's a lot of business
concerns going on now that has again
been turned out to be true as we find
out there are conversations between
Warner Brothers and Paramount about a
merger I'll talk about that a little bit
more in a minute I also told you that
actually the section 31 movie nearly
didn't happen happen because Michelle yo
was so busy that it was going to be a
series then it was going to be a
miniseries and then I told you guys that
they were going to do a movie again I
got told I was a liar because Michelle
yo always wanted to do Star Trek and
there was never any concerns but then we
found out that actually the Star Trek
section 31 TV movies only going ahead
because Michelle yo fought for it
because she was desperate to Paramount
gave her an out they said we could swipe
the contract and we can go our separate
ways and Michelle y went no no no I
would love to do this movie so because
of that we're getting it and it'll
actually be on our screens by the end of
this year so we have a divided fan base
we have a divided Paramount and we have
a lot of confusion about what's going on
with the show and we also have Legacy
which again I'll come back to in a bit
well there's still a lot of Doubt
because a lot of the things that going
to happen will be business decisions
they will be related to the bigger
picture of what's going on with these
two businesses Warner Brothers and
Paramount I'm being told that basically
this merger will be of Paramount not CBS
that CBS and Paramount will separate
once again that the existing owners will
continue with CBS and Paramount will
basically merge with Warner Brothers now
this is not Warner Brothers buying
Paramount this is one of the things when
we started hearing this rumor we
couldn't really understand because
obviously Warner Brothers is already $50
billion in debt how an earn could it
afford to pay for
Paramount the rumor is it won't this
deal is actually being pushed by Sher
Redstone who owns National amusements
she wants to limit her liability to some
of the $15 billion do wor the debt
Paramount owns because shareholders do
have certain liability and being the
biggest shareholder she is most liable
for that debt so instead of actually a
purchase they will transfer er a big
chunk of the $15 billion dollar worth of
debt that Paramount Global owes over to
Warner Brothers and with that certain
assets that Paramount Global currently
owns it will basically be Paramount
Studios and Paramount film and TV so the
studios and a lot of the IP that is
currently on by Paramount will move
across to Warner Brothers what does this
mean for Star Trek well I told you guys
a little while ago that Paramount Global
was planning to buy out Alex curtzman
and create Star Trek Studios from the
secret hideout business so Alex curtzman
will be paid off Paramount will
basically buy secret hideout and they
will set up this Star Trek Studios
coincidentally very similar to the model
that actual Warner Brothers has done
with DC creating DC Studios there are
business reasons why that's done tax
reasons why that's done but also like
just an internal structure sort of thing
where it's you know a team within a team
when you're doing something very
specific like that and it's a big
franchise like that it makes sense to
have a certain element of Separation so
Star Trek Studios would be owned by
Paramount Global but after the merger
who will own it well we're not a 100%
certain but one of the reasons why we've
had this rumor for several months and I
told you previously that they're going
to create the Star Trek Studios on one
hand they want to make Paramount a more
attractive proposition Star Trek is one
of the jewels in the crown over at
Paramount it is one of the franchises
that has the most value they want to
fully control that value and they want
to be able to make it sellable but we
didn't know about this merger idea and
all of a sudden this idea of Star Trek
Studios makes a little bit more sense in
another way you create a basically a
separate company it's a subsidiary of
Paramount Global and then when you're
talking to Warner Brothers about the
merger Star Trek Studios suddenly
becomes a separate entity it's another
piece on the chessboard will it go with
CBS or will it go with Paramount this
will not be a repeat of what we had
before when CBS and Paramount separated
when Paramount owned the movie rights to
Star Trek but CBS owned the TV rights
and we got JJ Abram Star Trek out of
it there will be one entity that owns
both and it will be Star Trek Studios
whether starrik Studios goes with
Paramount or goes with CBS though is
going to be the question this is a
little bit like a messy divorce and the
parents arguing over the child and we
currently have absolutely no way of
knowing which way that will fall but I
guarantee you it'll be one of the most
interestly debated topics over the
boardroom table when they are trying to
figure out the assets of this big
company now there is also just the
possibility that Paramount Global will
just merge entirely with Warner Brothers
and they will just take all of the debt
I'm being told that's reasonably
unlikely though because even though
there is more debt than actual asset to
parment Global currently the owners of
parment global don't consider that a
fair deal it would basically saying look
is Paramount Global worth $1 15 billion
do if somebody was going to try to buy
Paramount Global it would cost
significantly more than that even though
their stock market value is only
actually estimated at around $10 billion
at the end of the day MGM was valued at
$8.5 billion by Amazon just a couple of
years ago and well Paramount is a bigger
company than that so it's more likely
that they will do this separation of
assets why would Warner Brothers do it
because they want to then consolidate
all of that debt consolidate all of the
assets trim off a load of the fat and
actually consolidate a lot of the work
Paramount and Warner Brothers can then
do together they can basically continue
with the capacity they have now but for
much lower cost costs combined it's one
of those things that working together is
more efficient than working separately
and it's the only way both of these
companies can survive in the long run so
what is my prediction for Star Trek
one the new shows that we're going to be
seeing including strange new worlds um
season 3 will have significantly smaller
budgets than what we've seen previously
we've seen budgets that have gone over
$10 million an episode I'm being told
we're looking at far close to $7 million
an episode for all future Star Trek that
is um about a third knocked off and that
is basically what Paramount have said
almost all of their TV shows are going
to have to endure about a third knockof
the existing budgets sections 31 TV
movie will be on Paramount plus by the
end of this year filming begins in just
a couple of weeks and it's not being
done as a big cinematic movie it is
actually being done more of a long
episode really so yeah it'll be on SC
scen by the end of this year Strange New
World season 3 will be on S screens also
by the end of 2024 but it's probably
only going to be the first few episodes
this is something that's probably going
to either maybe have a release of the
first five episodes before Christmas and
then five episodes just after um but
they will be pretty much ready to go by
the end of 2024 or it'll be early 2025
at the latest Star Trek Legacy I am
predicting the Star Trek Legacy will be
announced in 2024 I have always argued
that I think Star Trek Legacy was
planned from day one I actually think
Paramount are doing exactly the same as
what they did with strange new worlds
I'm told strange new worlds was planned
from day one as soon as they brought
Pike into Discovery season two that
their idea was always they were going to
do the Strange New World spin-off but
they made out they weren't they got all
the fans to do all those you know
petitions and things and built up a real
excitement and then they got to say oh
look what we're do doing for the fans we
listened and we love you guys I actually
think if it wasn't for the strikes this
would have been announced already and
potentially if it wasn't also for
paramounts merger and business problems
I think this would have been announced
already but with that I think it will be
announced by the summer of this year
possibly after discovery season 5 ends I
don't think this will be on our screens
until 2025 but I think we will get to
hear a lot more about the development
plans for this series in 2024 I actually
think this is something else that could
end up being announced at San Diego
ComicCon the big thing though for Star
Trek in 2024 is that we will continue to
see TV shows being sold to different
providers by that I mean what we saw a
couple of years ago when basically
nothing was on Paramount plus everything
was either on Netflix um or Amazon Prime
I think we're going to see that a bit
more I'm actually being told that um
Star Trek Legacy will probably go to
Prime that that will be a partnership
between those two it's an extension
really from what they did with peard
obviously Prodigy has gone to Netflix
and lower deck um has already got a deal
again with prime all of these shows will
continue to appear first on power Mount
plus the decisions about what happens
with the merger with Warner Brothers is
really going to affect how this goes
forwards powermount plus has lost them a
crapload of money like HBO Max or just
max now has lost Warner Brothers a lot
of money over the years again
consolidating these streaming services
is the plan for the long term and there
is the possibility that actually Netflix
will be involved in that as well and
they'll create this sort of super
channel of Netflix Max and Paramount
plus bringing All Star Trek in together
but getting that investment money from
Prime is also going to be a big part of
the future for Star Trek it does seem
that Paramount consider Star Trek to be
one of their most valuable franchises
and something they can do lots and lots
of different things with but they can't
necessarily afford to do lots and lots
of different things with so continuing
that strategy of bringing in other
production companies like Amazon like
Netflix maybe Apple bringing in some of
that investment that allows them to
produce all of the different shows a
massive franchise like Star Trek
actually allows you to do do almost
Endless
Possibilities is going to be what we see
a lot more and actually the only way
we're going to be getting Legacy is if a
deal like that can be struck so that is
what I'm predicting for 2024 and Star
Trek but what are you predicting get to
the comments and tell me do you think
we're going to get Legacy announced this
year I'd love to know just yes or no
straight up and have you noticed that
I've not mentioned Starfleet Academy
which will also actually be going into
production this year but we won't get to
see an screen till
2025 what do you think about that I know
what I think but I'm not the one writing
the comments so you get in there and
tell me if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com cirre
where most of our new videos appear
first and you get to see them without
the adverts finally go to
c.g. which is our dedicated website
where we do stories based on a lot of
our videos and we try to add a little
bit more information for you to digest
go check it out as always please stay
safe and I'll see you next
[Music]
time